they're getting all this help they're
getting food they're getting all this
stuff that we don't have here's Joe
Rogan with Colin Noir on why poor people
in Chicago poor and black and brown
people will probably be voting for
Donald Trump this time around I think it
has a lot to do with Trump because you
know when he was running his campaign he
was running a lot of it based on the
idea he was going to build that Wilden
border and so that became that became a
separation point for a lot of people in
the country with respect to what side
they fell on and I think there's there's
a particular party in this country that
utilized it as a as a lightning rod to
create that level of division and so I
think they're kind of trying to
reestablish that again which is one of
the things is even more gangster about
Abbott sending people to Chicago sending
people to New York cuz in Chicago
they're like get these people here and
the people that live in Chicago the poor
people of Chicago like this is
these people getting money they're
getting they they're getting all this
help they're getting food they're
getting all this stuff that we don't
have yeah people literally in the place
who live there whole lives and then all
a sudden these people sneak in and
they're getting this special treatment
you get it Rogan gets it Colin gets it
you know why do I show you these clips
of Rogan all the time it's not like he
needs the promotion it's because he's
just he's basically a pot smoking
mushroom eating libertarian UFC guy who
has been smashed in the face like they
took a cast iron pan and they bashed him
in the face with reality and suddenly
he's going boy I guess none of this
Lefty stuff makes sense anymore and I
think many many people feel that so the
question is what will happen in this
next election can this it's not a
political party can this movement that's
Loosely based on freedom that is told
that it's racist and homophobic but
actually isn't can it coales around
something that something actually seems
to be Donald Trump right now for all his
flaws like he is the thing that
represents the way out of this that's
just kind of where we're
at